hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled identification of human immune
cell subtypes most vulnerable to il1b
induced inflammatory signaling using
mass cytometry i'm susie valdez of
labyrinth and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by fluiden
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during this presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask question box
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen i now present
today's speaker dr hema cathari
an assistant professor of the department
of medicine cardiovascular medicine
division
at the university of virginia for a
complete biography on
dr catharie please visit the biography
tab at the top
of your screen doctors qatari
you may now begin your presentation
welcome
thank you for the introduction and hello
everyone out there watching this
presentation
in today's talk i'll be sharing data on
how we utilize the
powerful mass cytometry approach to
identify the immune cell subtypes in
humans
that are targeted by the
pro-inflammatory cytokine il1 beta
we hope that this work and other ongoing
projects in our lab
will contribute towards a better
understanding of the
inflammatory immune response to covet 19
and help develop potential strategies
for assessing
disease severity and response to therapy
for better
outcomes before i
show you our data i'll talk briefly
about the cytokine storm in kovite 19
the role of il1 beta in cytokine storm
and tissue injury
and then i'll discuss few recent
findings
that show the potential of targeting il1
beta
for treating the cytokine storm in
mortality
the coveted 19 cases across a number of
countries are still on the rise
here is a snapshot of the number of the
confirmed coveted 19 cases between
june 17th to june 23rd across different
countries
and if you go back and check on the
whole site
you would realize that just in this past
week there has been an increase of ten
percent in the number of confirmed cases
and about six percent increase in the
number of deaths
covet 19 infected subjects show a range
of clinical symptoms some of them while
infected remain
asymptomatic while others develop
mild to moderate disease and recover
and then there are a subset of
individuals that have severe outcomes
such as pneumonia arts multi-organ
failure and death
we know that people with comorbidities
such as
hypertension hyperlipidemia diabetes and
other underlying conditions
and the elderly are at higher risk
recent studies suggest that immune
dysregulation
and cytokine storm lead to disease
severity and mortality in covid19
shown here in the figure is the immune
response in subjects with mild to
moderate disease
so the way the sas cov2 virus gains
entry into the cell
is through binding to the as2 receptor
which is
expressed on lung epithelial cells and
then
through cleavage of its spike protein by
the serine protease tmprss2
in addition uh pattern recognization
receptors on innate immune cells
such as macrophages can also sense to
rna viruses
in most individuals the interaction of
this virus triggers an efficient immune
response
such as production of type 1 interferons
shown over here in yellow and other
pro-inflammatory cytokines
such as dnf alpha il-1 beta il-6
and others this helps
clear the viral infection with minimal
inflammation
and tissue damage and however
in high risk subjects with severe
disease the antiviral response is not
efficient enough
and leads to an uncontrolled viral
replication and a dysfunctional immune
response
this in turn drives a massive production
in of cytokines that leads to severe
lung
inflammation coagulopathies organ
failure
and depth il1 beta is one of the
inflammatory cytokines
higher levels of which are present in
covid19 patients with severe disease
the different mechanisms through which
il1 beta can contribute to severe
disease
is through causing cell pyroptosis
production of other downstream
inflammatory cytokines such as il6
tns alpha interferon gamma and so on
and induction of the coagulation protein
tissue factor
on macrophages lung epithelial cells and
endothelial cells
bile one beta can also recruit
immune inflammatory cells to the site of
inflammation
and can induce immune cell proliferation
and differentiation
in addition to il1 beta there are other
cytokines in chemical and some of them
that i have listed over here
are being shown to be associated with
severe disease
and mortality in covid19 patients
so the way il1 beta influences the
cellular functions
is through binding to its cell surface
receptor il1 receptor 1
and its interaction with the core
receptor il1 receptor 3
this primary complex then triggers a
series of intracellular events
that ultimately leads to the activation
of an s kappa b
ap1 as well as map kinases and dries the
gene transcription
there are different inhibitors of il1
that are
used in the clinics mostly for treating
chronic inflammatory diseases
such as rheumatoid arthritis gout and
other autoinflammatory diseases
one of them is anakinra which is an il1
receptor antagonist and the way it
blocks il1 beta signaling is by binding
to the cell surface receptor il1
receptor 1.
i want to mention that anakinrak can
inhibit signaling mediated by both forms
of il1
which are il1 alpha and il1 beta
kanakimumab on the other hand is a
monoclonal antibody that is specific to
il1 beta a third
a third inhibitor of il1 beta
used is reliant sept which is basically
a fusion protein
and similar to anakinra it can also
inhibit signaling mediated by both
isoforms of il1
given the evidence of the cytokine storm
in severe covid19 infection
multiple clinical trials are testing the
potential of anti-inflammatory
agents such as inhibitors of il1 beta
il-6 and jack signaling proteins
currently
two of the recent studies that were
published
show the potential of anakinra for
reducing
inflammation and mortality in covert 19
patients
one of them is the study by thomas hugh
at all from france
which assessed the off-label use of
anakinra in patients with severe forms
of covid19
in this study they used two cohorts of a
prospective cohort of 52 subjects that
were treated with anakinra
100 milligrams twice a day for 72 hours
and then 100 milligrams daily for seven
days
the control cohort enrolled
retrospectively following the same
inclusion criteria
was treated with the standard therapy
alone
the results showed significantly lower
risk for death or admission to the icu
for invasive mechanical ventilation
in patients treated with anakinra as
compared to the control group
a second study by cavalier g at all from
italy
also showed positive outcomes with
anacambra
the three arms in this trial were a
cohort of 16 patients that just received
the standard therapy
a cohort of seven patients that were
treated with hundred milligrams anakinra
twice a day
for 21 days and then a third cohort
of 29 patients that received a high dose
of anakinra
for 21 days in this study lower dose and
a kindred treatment was discontinued
after seven days
because there were there was no effect
on serum crp levels and clinical status
however higher dose anakinra treatment
showed clinical improvement
in terms of increased survival and
reduction in the need for mechanical
ventilation
the possible reason for the discrepancy
in the outcomes with low dose anakinra
between these two studies
could be the differences in the status
of the control group
as in the other study by thomas u at all
the authors did mention
that their control group comprised of
subjects that were more obese
and that could possibly have confounded
the results
while il-1 beta inhibitors are emerging
as a potential therapy for inflammatory
disorders
it is unclear which specific cell types
in humans
il-1 data targets and whether it
activates different signaling pathways
in different immune cell subsets
to answer these questions we designed a
custom 35 antibody siteoff panel
consisting of cell surface markers for
broad identification
of major immune cell subsets il1
receptors
and intracellular phospho-signaling
proteins
we then performed optimizations our
future
goal is to use this panel for immune
phenotyping tbmcs from subjects and
clinical trials
therefore we first confirmed expression
of markers
in cryopreserve pbmcs by comparing them
with fresh
and results were very comparable all
antibodies were titrated and we ensured
that there is no bleed through
that may arise as a result of metal
impurity or metal oxidation
finally as we were interested in
detecting transient phosphorylation
events and the cells needed to be fixed
we evaluated the effect of pfa fixative
as well as
methanol that is used for cell
permeabilization
on cell surface marker epitopes
we found that pfa alters antibody
reactivity
and this was especially the case for the
chemokine receptors as shown over here
the staining was either severely
diminished
such as um in c for the case for ccr7
cxcr5 or enhanced non-specifically
as you can see here for the chemokine
receptor
3 cxcr3 in order to stain tbmc samples
with these pfa libel antibodies
we then adopted an alternative strategy
where we added these antibodies at the
same time of cell stimulation with il1
beta
and incubated the cells with the
antibodies for 15 minutes
we evaluated if any body addition
affects the signaling outcome and
found no effect as you can see over here
in these two figures
where left was with no antibodies added
and in the b figure the antibodies were
added at the same time of il1 beta
stimulation
and there was no change in the frequency
of the phosphor nf kappa b positive cell
here is our experimental setup that we
used for our
studies we used cryopreserve pbmcs from
healthy donors that were thought
rested and stimulated with il1 beta in
the presence of the tfa labial
antibodies
cells were then fixed with pfa and
barcoded
before stained with the cell surface or
other intracellular antibodies
samples were run inside of and acquired
data was then analyzed using the r-based
computational algorithms side of bank
and by traditional gating
to identify the immune cell subtypes
that respond to il-1 beta stimulation we
first performed spade analysis in
cytobank
state is an algorithm to analyze
multi-parameter data and the way it
works is it basically like puts the
phenotypically similar cells in a
cluster
and then generates a 2d tree of those
clusters
figure a shown over here shows the
localization of the different immune
cell subsets
such as cd4 t cell cd19 t
cell cd8 t cells and so on
the size of each circle and color in
this particular figure depicts the
number of the cells
so blue color depicts less cell count
and red color shown over here depicts
a higher cell count the clusters were
defined
as cd4 t cell cd8 t cells b
cells or monocytes and so on based on
the median expression of the lineage
markers
as shown in figure b the color here
blue to red represents low to high
marker expression
uh figure c shows expression of phospho
in escapa b
phosphop38 and phosphoerc across all
immune cell subtypes
in vehicle treated which is the top
panel and the il1 beta stimulated
samples which is the bottom panel
here the treatment was this figure is
coming from the cell samples that were
treated with il1 beta for 15 minutes
as you can see il1 beta induced
nf kappa b activation within the cd4 t
cells cd4 negative cd8
low t cells cd11c
myeloid dendritic cells and to some
extent in the natural killer cells
p38 activation was observed
primarily in the cd14 monocyte cd11c
dendritic cells and to some
lower level in some of the cd4 t cells
as seen
here within the cd4 bubble
as compared to vehicle there was no
change in the erc activation upon il1
beta stimulation
i just want to emphasize one more thing
that the scale over here
for the three different phosphor
proteins are different
so although the color red is there but
the level of earth activation either
basal
or under stimulated conditions was lower
as compared to phosphop38 and phosphons
kappab
to identify um the specific immune cell
subsets
even within like what are the specific
cell subsets within cd4
t cells or within the monocytes we then
performed
umap and leiden clustering we clustered
the t
cells monocytes and nk cells separately
and the cells that we used for our
clustering analysis
are shown as um are shown in the figure
so we
used this particular excellent gated
with this gate as shown in figure d
for t cells and then as shown in figure
e
these two gates we used either the cd56
positive hladr negative cells for the
natural killer cell clustering
or the dr positive cells for monocyte
and dendritic cell clustering
we identified um 12 distinct t cell
clusters
and when we projected the clusters on a
umap which is a model of dimensionality
reduction
that condenses everything down to two
dimensions
you can see that the cd4 t cells shown
here on top of the umap
and the cd8 t cells the red
the clusters 2 10 and 11 at the bottom
of the umap
they were distinctly separated from each
other as anticipated
we then determine the frequency of these
clusters in the subjects which is shown
in figure b
and as anticipated there was
heterogeneity in cluster abundance
between the subjects
phenotype of the t cell clusters was
annotated
based on the expression of the markers
as shown on the heat map
here in figure c where blue to high
color
in the scale depicts low to high
expression
and in addition to the heat map we also
used the violin plots to annotate these
clusters um the violin plots are not
shown on the slide
and as an example we identified cluster
12 as
memory t-rex based on the expression of
cd4 cd25
cd45 ro and the lack of expression of
ccr7 sorry cd127
um having annotated the clusters we
identified robust activation of nf kappa
b in clusters
3 4 8 and 12 in response to il1 beta
these clusters corresponded to ts17
cells t follicular helper cells cd4
negative cd8 low cd 161 high t
cells and memory t and memory t-rex
uh we also found phospho nf sorry
activation of p38
within the same clusters but the level
of activation of p38
was much lower as compared to the nf
kappa b
interestingly we identified that
all of the four subsets that respond to
il1 beta
are effector memory t cells as defined
by the expression of cd45 ro
and lack of expression of ccr7
next we were curious to see
if the expression of il1 receptor 1
which transmits il1 beta signaling
is limited to the cells that respond to
il1 beta
to test this we separated total t cells
into phosphorus nf kappa b negative and
phosphory nf kappa b positive
populations
and then measured expression of il1
receptor 1.
surprisingly we observed a significantly
lower
expression of receptor one on the
phosphor nf kappa b positive cells
as compared to the phospho nf kappa b
negative cells
under in cells that were treated with
either vehicle control
or il1 data this data suggests
a difference in the expression of other
proteins either
cell surface or intracellular that may
regulate
il1 beta signaling response
il1 receptor 2 is another cell surface
protein
that binds il1 beta but it acts as a
decoy receptor in that it doesn't
transmit the
downstream signaling so thus
the ratio of receptor 1 and receptor 2
on a cell may affect the final signaling
outcome
unfortunately we could not detect il-1
receptor 2 in our sight-off analysis
however using the same antibody clone
we were able to measure il1 receptor 2
expression in pvmcs
that were cultured in the presence of
ntcd3
ntcd28 and il2 and you can see over here
in the in the figure on the right hand
side the middle panel
that even some level of il1 receptor 2
expression was seen
in cells that were cultured for 48 hours
but were not stimulated with the
t cell activating factors shown here on
the right most is the fmo control
that we use to gate the il1 receptor
positive population
a deeper look to identify
the unique marker that marks the t cells
that respond to il1 beta
we found that expression of ccr6
is a common feature among the four
clusters that showed signaling
activation
although the expression of ccr6 varied
between the four clusters
to find out if ccr6 expression would
identify the responsive cells
we separated the total t cells into ccr6
negative and ccr6 positive t cells
and then analyzed for the expression of
nf phospho ns kappa b
and phosphop38 um interestingly as shown
in figure
b over here the uh the nf kappa b
positive cells were enriched within the
ccr6 positive t
cells we observed the same with
phosphop38 positive t
cells furthermore up to 60 percent of
the ccr
6 positive cd4 ma sorry
ccr 6 positive t cells
that responded to il1 beta stimulation
also co expressed ccr2 and cd26
as shown here in the umap overlays
following similar steps we identified
the monocyte clusters
annotated them and determined their
abundance in different subjects
we identified nf catholic activation in
the cd14
classical monocyte subsets cluster 1
2 6 and 9 as well as in the cd11c
myeloid dendritic cell which is cluster
eight shown over here
in addition il1 beta also stimulated
nf kappa b um phosphons kappa b
in cluster 12 which was found to be a
linear negative cell that only
expressed cd38
we don't know what that cell type is yet
p38 activation was also observed within
these same subsets
for clustering nk cells we used the
classic broad nk cell markers
uh such as cd56 cd16 and cd161
and also included other markers as shown
over here on figure c
heat map that we found that were
expressed on the
nk cells after clustering
we identified 17 clusters
and found an f kappa b activation
induced by il1 beta
in cluster in clusters 2
3 and 17. interestingly
cluster 17 that showed the most robust
activation of phosphor nf
activation of nf kappa b and p38 was
found to be the one that uniquely
expressed cd25
cluster 2 corresponded to the cd56
dim cd16 dim population and cluster
3 was the cd56 bright cd16 negative
population
this cluster 17 that expresses cd25
we suspect that these cells could be
either some sort of
innate lymphoid cells or activated nk
cells but
further studies are needed to confirm
their identity
we also evaluated indirect signaling
mediated by il1 beta
by stimulating cells for longer time
points as you can see
il-1 beta stimulation led to a transient
early activation of nf kappa b in t cell
subsets shown over here
that peaked at 15 minutes and then was
reduced to basal levels at later time
points
monocytes cd 11c dendritic cells and nk
cell subsets
also showed similar kinetics of nf kappa
b
and p38 activation but it's not shown
over here
in contrast longer stimulation with il1
beta
for one hour or more led to differential
activation of stat
1 stack 3 and stat 5
in subsets of t cells monocytes and nk
cells
shown here is the data for stat 3
activation in t cell subsets which
clearly shows the donor heterogeneity
and the response
as well as the differential activation
in the different t
cell subtypes for detailed information
for people who might be interested in
knowing more about the specific immune
cell subsets and the direct and indirect
signaling response mediated by il1 beta
please refer to our online manuscript in
the bio archive
um so finally as
anticipated we found that anakinra
inhibits il1 beta induced signaling
as shown here for ns kappa b activation
in the ccr6 positive t
cells cd14 positive monocytes
cd11c myeloid dendritic cells and the
cd25 expressing nk cell cluster
we have other ongoing projects in the
lab
that are focused on testing and
developing immune based signatures
for personalized anti-inflammatory
therapy for cvd
and i thought that i'll just share this
small piece of data
that was done in the heart failure
subjects
so similar to the healthy subjects
in the heart failure subjects l1 beta
induced nf kappa b
activation specifically in the th17
cells
as well as in the cd11c myeloid
dendritic cells
the interesting finding here is that
there is remarkable heterogeneity
in response to il1 beta stimulation as
well as to inhibition by anakinra
we anticipate seeing such heterogeneity
in the covid19
infected patients and we believe that
immune phenotyping these subjects
using a similar approach may discover
immune biomarkers for early
identification of covid19 patients
at risk of cytokine storm and those that
might respond to agents that block
cytokine storm
so finally to summarize uh we have
identified the immune cell subsets that
respond to il1 beta
ccr6 expression was found to be as a
marker for identifying the t
cells that respond to il-1 beta
il-1 beta induced ms kappa b activation
more prominently than p-38 in t
cells dendritic cells and nk cells we
did not
find activation of erc or jnk
by il1 beta stimulation in any cell
subtype
and as compared to other immune cell
subsets
b cell seems to be quite unresponsive to
il1 beta stimulation
and we think that the activation of
stats that we observed at later time
points after il-1 data stimulation
is most likely arising as a result of
the production of other downstream
uh pro-inflammatory cytokines such as
il-6 intraoceron gamma or gmcsf
and that work is currently ongoing in
the lab to look more
into it finally for my acknowledgements
um i'm really thankful to my mentor dr
colleen mcnamara
as well as all the wonderful people in
her lab that
makes work really fun and exciting for
the
il-1 beta specific work um shantel mex
gaming
and michael vignesh were really
contributed significantly for that
project i'm really thankful to
my collaborator dr eli zander in the
biomedical engineering department and
his phd student corey williams
for their help with data analysis
and finally i would like to acknowledge
the wonderful flow cytometry core people
at uva
and aha for supporting this work thank
you
and thank you dr kasari for that
informative presentation
and we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar
audience members if you have questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
so it looks like dr katharine that we
already have some questions
coming in from our audience members our
first question
what do you think are the reasons for
the variability in the donor response
to il1b
yeah that's a great question and
as we initially we thought that it could
be
the level of the receptor one or the
receptor receptor two present on the
cell surface that will determine
the response in the donor but then like
based on our t
cell data it kind of like suggests that
it is a little bit independent of the
receptor one
and there could be multiple factors for
that one of them
is we think that definitely there will
be
like uh it is genetically encoded
so we know that there is polymorphism in
il1 receptor
as well as the other intracellular
signaling proteins such as
mid-88 and so that could
be one of the really possible reason
that why
subjects show differential response and
then what we have not currently measured
is the level of the other signaling
proteins as well as the core receptors
that uh mediate the eye that mediate the
signaling
so uh in all i think the interaction
between them
dictate the signaling outcomes so the
levels of
the different receptors and the core
receptors
i think also makes a difference in the
signaling outcome
and that's how that impacts the donor
heterogeneity in response to l1 beta
thank you for that response one audience
member wants to know
do you plan to also measure downstream
intracellular signaling proteins
involved in the il
1b pathway yeah of
a do and uh we've been like we have
spent some time
now um trying to do that one and one of
the major
uh problem is that we don't have
currently we don't have the antibodies
like good antibodies that are compatible
for flow or site off um and we are we
have uh kind of like tried to find
different antibodies we have some
that we are currently validating uh but
it is tough i just
hope that the the fluidized people or
other company people like come up with
these
other antibodies that are really
important such as for the il1 beta
pathway or il6 pathway
because that would make our work really
easier and it would provide more
insights a deeper insight into what's
exactly going on so yeah we are looking
forward to it but uh some some work is
ongoing and we don't have
all those antibodies
thank you dr and again thank you to our
audience members
any questions not as answered today will
be answered via email
we have time for a couple more questions
before we close
how did you decide to use umap
as opposed to all the other clustering
all the resins um
available um yeah so
uh that's a good question um in the way
so
we use uh spade and i personally like
spa uh to use spade
because then uh when we are working with
example looking
at intracellular signaling and our
question is like how it
uh impacts the different cell subsets so
spate provides a quick
overview it is to look at
what's going on across different immune
cell cell subsets
and then we can go on into more deeper
other clustering algorithms which are
more complicated but at the same time
they provide more detailed information
and it is also much easier i know i mean
with spade you can still get the
more quantitative data from each node
and other things but it is
i think to me it is a little bit more
time taking as compared to
using other clustering algorithms like
uh leiden or looping
if you have the right people to help you
out with those
analysis thank you so much
one last question is anyone studying the
il-1
beta pathways in covid patients with
adverse
heart impact
so my answer to that question would be i
think it is very much
likely i'm not completely aware of that
one
but uh we know that a lot of the
patients who are getting
severe symptoms after a covid 19
infection
they have these comorbidities and a lot
of them have
cardiac issues so i think that's a valid
reason and
inflammation is a common pathway for the
pathogenesis of both
and we are seeing that in coped 19
infected patients a lot of them are
dying due to
these coagulopathies or heart related
problems
so that's an important area to study and
i believe like somebody is definitely
studying that
sorry thank you again for today's
presentation and
very important research i also want to
thank fluidine
for sponsoring today's event and
encourage audience members to check out
other presentations and explore the
virtual environments and booths
and before we go i want to thank
audience members for joining us today
and for their interesting questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
through july of 2021
until next time have a great day stay
safe
thank you thank you
you